from the oscar-winning film Selma please
welcome David Oh yellow oh hello and
welcome to the Academy's scientific and
technical Awards my name is indeed David
Oh yellow and I am honored to stand
amongst my peers no not my technical
peers because I wouldn't know a b-spline
from a specular map but I mean my
mispronounced name Pierce
yes you know what I'm talking about
Bielefeld Paolini table oh you're
assuming and aqua Vela you are my people
I'm really happy to be with you at the
SciTech Awards just this one time
and I've already hosted this show more
than Johnny Carson I'm here Lee purely
for the bragging rights we've got some
great awards tonight Photoshop is here
yeah yeah yeah yeah receiving an award
this evening they are they weren't
originally one of tonight's honorees but
a very quick few brush strokes and what
do you know they Photoshop themselves
into the program sneaky very sneaky
the team from Pixar here yes it's
exciting to have some non visual effects
people here welcome now picks is being
honored tonight for creating a digital
daily system that offers access anywhere
including on a boat isn't that great
while editors and artists are toiling
away at their workstations jacked up on
diet coke a movie executive is on there
you're giving notes yeah
it's true now before we get into the
festivities and the inevitable rumble
between light stage X and Medusa guys
guys both facial appearance capture and
facial geometric actor are important
okay we know that so let's just keep it
classic I do want to say how honored I
am to be here celebrating with you all
beyond the glam of the red carpet and
the parade of limousines the reason we
celebrate is because someone had a story
to tell that is the art and telling that
story requires tool that is the science
it's easy to get wrapped up in the
awards season fever but we shouldn't
forget that making
great film requires greater talent from
start to finish the work you've done to
advance the art and science of motion
pictures is invaluable and often times
unrecognized not tonight so let us begin
our first two awards will be for motion
graphics as purely an art form the roots
of motion graphics can be traced back
100 years ago to the animation of
abstract images by Walter Ruttman forty
years later the technique progressed
with mechanical analog computer graphics
created by pioneer john whitney motion
graphics have been famously used by sol
bass who created unforgettable title
sequences in the man with the Golden Arm
vertigo and dozens of other classic
films currently the impact of motion
graphics can be seen in almost every
movie you watch tonight we celebrate two
systems that continue to raise the bar
to help artists create beautiful design
and animation first it's magrav
two pair Anders Arvid Edwards for his
work on mograph the Academy presents a
technical achievement award charondas
please come up
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you and thank you to the
Academy and of course thank you to the
brush and staff making this evening so
great for all of us oh it says wow what
an amazing gift it's a huge privilege
I've gotten to see how what I make
mograph has impacted and changed the
industry and people's lives our
brilliant artists have taken its places
I never even conceived
they've conveyed messages that have
changed the world and shaped new ones
I've gotten to see how it's helped Maxon
grow massively and now on top of all
that this recognition for innovation I
mean that's loaded word right innovation
being an innovator huge privilege ask
anyone and they'll tell you it means you
know a person that comes up with
original ideas completely unlike every
single other person on the face of the
planet
come on ideas a 10 a penny the real
difference is we all of us here we get
to make it happen and having the means
to do that for your own ideas that's a
huge privilege we make it ourselves but
everyone else that bought into our
craziness that taught us that nurtured
us and supported us they deserve credit
and I want to thank them I want to thank
my wonderful wife Shira who's shown a
remarkable sense of humor by staying
with me all these years I want to thank
my parents who showed me how to live
grow and Excel and taught me how to be
an innovator and though they're no
longer with us they continue to give me
everything of course I want to thank the
rest of my brilliant and annoyingly /
accomplished family I'm selfie
underachiever why and I want to thank
max on past and present you guys created
cinema 4d and without you mo Groff would
not exist
it's you're insanely talented developers
and staff that share in the glory of
this award in particular I want to thank
Oliver Phillip Christian and Tilo
Paul Everett fen Wilfred and Bjorn Paul
and Rick Herveaux
arrest us Sebastian and everyone else
that keeps McGrath alive and well and
works so hard to make Maxon fertile
grounds for creativity original thought
and innovation and of course I want to
thank our wonderful users like Marty
who's here tonight who supported me the
most this is all for you once again
thank you to the Academy and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]